You know,
man,
it's like even what's going on with the
pope just recently said there's no hell.
And everybody went crazy.
Like what? What did Hsi,
the pope said, there's no hell. He's,
he's slowly bracing you for the
fact that all this is nonsense,
but right now we're going to get rid
of hell. Like this is like one of the,
one of the purest examples of like the
change in people's attitudes towards a
religious real. Yup. Yup.
The Vatican denies that,
but the Vatican did not say,
there is no hell,
we'll find out an article where it says,
he did say that 50% shit,
he's not going to cut it back.
Go back in time and find an article
where he did say the guarantee you,
he did say it. Let's just assume at
one day that, see this is what they do.
They say it a little bit
and then they take it back.
So they get used to the idea that they're
saying it. That's what it is. I'm,
I'm full Eddie Bravo right now.
I'm full conspiracy dude.
This is how they set it up.
They start out with uh, uh, uh,
they tell you the hell is not real.
And then they say, we never said that.
And then a year from now they say, look,
we're pretty sure hell is not real. This,
this pope probably place fort night and
shit. And he's like, he's a cool pope.
He doesn't have the pope. He's got his
Connie liaison. He's the cool pope.
He is the cool pope. He got rid
of the throne. Oh yeah. Yeah.
He had a big giant crazy ass thrown
for the last guy. The creeper.
He's got a Gamer chair down those
racing chairs. The headphones.
It's got one of those Pope
Francis in the fucking house.
Pope Francis has no problem
with gay people either.
See Pope Francis fighting with Yo litter
kid. Yeah. See, look how he swapped.
You look at the old, the old thrown versus
the new look at the two side to side.
The guy on the left to God,
they just kicked out for crimes against
humanity and the guy on the right is the
new guy who's just got a sensible
chair. Much better. Yeah,
the throne is creepy man.
That is crazy.
And He dresses much more conservatively
two. He's not wearing crazy wizard robes.
He's wearing like a one color wizard robe.
He dresses like r Kelly on a Sunday.
Just crazy.
Like if he came out and like a
polo shirt and a pair of jeans. No,
right? No. Everybody like,
hey you can't be the Paul put
without the fucking magic outfit.
Where's your fish head hat? Come
on Bro. He's got body armor on.
He's got that hat on like a golden salmon
that's coming out of the top of his
head. Like show me that
hat is fucking hat.
Sad is preposterous. That's out.
That's like a monster and a,
that's a mouth of a monster. I
ah, like a like a giant snake.
It looks like a Napkin at a restaurant
when you go there and it's sitting in.
Oh and it's nicely done in south Wales.
A little rings.
He probably put it on by mistake.
Like he's just like, look at me.
I can't believe they're making fun of our
Holy Father Cause just on this fucking
show sucks.
You'll make it fun of our Holy Father.
He's right there with the smoke.
Oh my God.
How is this still legal?
Look at these kids dressed up like
they're in Harry Potter's seminary until
Dwarf that. They look good. They do.
They look like they'd go to that.
What's that Hogwarts school. They
do. This is fucking ridiculous.
Universal talking to this dude who's
holding up a golden version of where the
savior was murdered,
right?
He's got a golden cross is crosses all
over the place like don't forget about
the cross, and he standing
there dressed like a wizard.
This is craziness and everybody's
gonna know this is our religion.
This is our culture. This
is weird. This is weird,
and I'm not saying it's not beautiful.
It's absolutely beautiful.
I'm not saying it's any weirder than
going to the opera because I think that's
weird too,
but this shit is weird.
This is some really old form of education
slash entertainment that people used
to do before they had plays.
They get together and some room.
What's fucking crazy?
Different colored glass windows in it.
Why didn't he have a mic on?
Why did that kid got to hold the mic?
And because Jesus doesn't
want him to be magnified.
That's a thick mic though.
Yeah. Manager. It was pink.
She had a pink Mike. What's the deal?
What's up? Why's it have to be silver?
I like pink, pink, pink Mike. It's uh,
it's crazy, you know, and it's a
billion of us and I was raised there.
I mean I was from when I was real little
kid did at least one year in Catholic
school, but was around a lot of
Catholics. You know, I don't,
I'm not claiming to be an expert in it,
but I don't have to be that Shit's
bananas. I used to be an altar server.
I used to hold that. Mike,
did you really? Did you,
were you ever in the middle of doing
that? Going, what in the fuck am I doing?
Not,
well the most of the times we did it
when it and me and my friends talk about,
we would get out of class so we would,
because I went to Catholic school,
there'd be services during the day and
funerals even sometimes we get paid to be
out of class and then we would like
miss two or three hours of school.
Wow,
20 bucks, get some donuts, miss lunch. You
know? That was really all we were doing.
I used to just have to light the candles
like me and this other kid would come
out and late.
All these candles.
I always wanted to be the guy that puts
them out with that bell bell and the
hook.
That's so bananas when you're
in that room and they'll see,
you see those benches all laid out up
to the pulpit like this is so crazy.
This is,
it's,
it's like people figured out some way
to make the bridge between physical
evolution and mental evolution.
Like there's this bridge between
us not being monkeys anymore,
but still we just want to get
out of the barbarian behavior.
We've got to figure out a way to get
people to like have reverence for
something.
It's all and just control their behavior.
We've got to slow down the chimp in a
set a monkey and that's what it looks
like. A monkey. The monkey statue,
the feast of the chair of Saint
Peter and addressed what is the,
the statue is just a bronze statue
of Saint Peter is a dark statue.
Try and tell you St Peter was black
truth.
There's a, it's weird. When we
were in Charlottesville, the,
they had the black Israelites there that
were right out in front of the building.
They'll,
they used to set up shop all the time
and New York is to run into those dudes.
Just wander down the street. I was told
that because I'm Italian, I'm not white.
I said, Oh yeah, two told me that. I
was like, thank you and do you see true?
I know what you are. I did
see that. I did see that,
but yet I'm certainly not black,
so keep telling it.
According to these black Israelites,
I am not white, so I'm okay.
The nit true nation. Is that them?
Cause I love how they dress. They,
I mean they take that whole
pope shit to the next level.
They're like fuck that man won't be
like he mad master of the universe.
God Damn dressing. It's crazy.
Look at how they're dressing.
They have shields and shit bro. Go
to that. Make that picture bigger.
Please make that picture bigger. These
are serious people there on the street.
They're reading from the Bible. One
guy has a sword, kids guys got an ax.
The other guys got to pick acts
like he's going to go find gold.
This is one of the craziest pictures
of this is real. Is that real champion?
Be Real. That's like, go
back to that please. Jamie,
go back to that police for a
second. What did, what did it say?
There was something in the um, the
text that went with it. Is that it?
Yeah, there it is. What does
it say? Passover 2012 Isu p. K.
Passover from Wikipedia.
So
it looks like a mix tape.
What is that High Holy Day
Passover in Harlem, New York.
2012. Oh my God. So that's the black
Israelites at the high holy day.
Passover,
black Israelites who think there are
different kinds of Jew that the so called
Jews that looks like
fun. I'll do that. Um,
it looks like fun until someone gets
drunk and starts swinging an ax around.
What do they got there?
They're teaching white people stuff.
They got these posters. Six, six,
six. Preach on brother. Okay.
They dress cool though. Look at that
outfit. All leather. Giant star.
David Dude has a sword. No big deal. Just
two dudes walking around with a stored
there. It is like a fucking like, oh, it
looks like a holiday inn or something.
Right? This isn't like some sort of
banquet center. When they have the sword,
they showed the picture of the sword.
Where are they?
Where the fuck is that going on that?
That seems like a very public place.
That was sword. So what's that place
to eat at? And they all look like that.
Your Horse Chow stows medieval manner
type places. It'll eat the times.
Maybe two times.
Yeah.